welcome to the man of Recaps this is Gen
V season 1 welcome to the world of the
boys where superheroes are generally the
villains and the superhero Mega
Corporation vot is up to all sorts of
evil stuff specifically the boys just
exposed that superheroes were not born
but made by secretly injecting babies
with the dangerous chemical compound V
so now at the superhero College gulin
University God you the next generation
of young superheroes have come to terms
with their compound V Origins and are
optimistic to make the world better we
follow freshman Marie Maro who had a
nice happy childhood with her parents
and sister but when she unexpectedly
manifested blood Powers she was unable
to control them and accidentally killed
her parents and so Marie was sent to a
superhero orphanage where no one wanted
to adopt her cuz blood powers are gross
but she worked her butt off and got in
to God you where she's excited to learn
to be a real hero but she was not
accepted to the crime fighting school
there's very few slots for actual Heroes
most super people just end up being
actors she pleads her case to the
legendary Professor Brink but he doesn't
care about her he only cares about the
strongest Heroes like his Golden Boy
Luke whose superhero name is Golden Boy
he has Human Torch flame on Powers and
is generally a top tier soup but that
night a crazed student is out of control
and eager to prove herself Marie helps
stop him Luke's best friend Andre saw
her in action and invites Marie out to
hang with the cool kids and they're a
good group Golden Boy is actually a
really nice guy his girlfriend Kate has
compulsion Powers if she touches you you
have to do what she says their other
friend Jordan is very strong too and
their powers involve switching genders
at will Andre has metal powers like
Magneto but when he going off someone
bumps him and oh he accidentally hits
someone but Marie manages to use her
blood powers to save her oh yes Marie's
a hero but her reward is being expelled
yeah to protect their top students
they're blaming hitting the girl on
Marie so unjust meanwhile there's
something going on with Luke he keeps
having visions of being in the woods
with his dead brother and just as Marie
goes back to Brink's office golden boy's
in there and has just killed him he
comes from Marie to eliminate the
witness but luckily his friend Jordan's
there to stop him their boy forms for
defense and girl forms for offense but
it's finally Andre who talks his friend
down and Luke feels so bad about what he
did oh no he kills himself so vot
executive Ashley Barrett from the boys
is here to put a spin on things and
focus on the heroes who stopped him so
Marie now finds herself thrust into the
spotlight famous overnight as the
Guardians of gulin Andre is more used to
this media circus his father was the
famous soup polarity who's droom and his
son to take his place one day but Andre
doesn't care about PR right now he and
Kate want to figure out why their best
friend Luke killed Brink in the first
place and as they over the loss of their
best friend and boyfriend grief is
Nature's Most Powerful aphrodesiac these
two get it on so Andre does some
snooping and discovers the woods the
secret science lab in the basement where
VA is experimenting on students and the
Escape E from the beginning is Luke's
Brother Sam who is not dead he's a
prisoner down here Andre tries to tell
his dad but it's like son you got to
drop this or they'll kill you yes his
dad knows and now Andre is mad at his
father now meet Murray's roommate Emma
who's super fun and friendly she has a
moderately successful YouTube channel as
little Cricket because she's got
shrinking Powers but using her powers is
not fun she shrinks by throwing up she
confides this to a new friend who then
outs her secret for views so she's had a
rough start to the school year so Andre
tells her about the woods and she's
excited to use her powers for good she
sneaks in and meets Sam hey I'm here to
rescue you that involves taking out a
guard but not with an Ant-Man PG-13
punch but by disgustingly crawling
through his brain anyway they escape and
hide out in an old Drive-In and Sam's
kind of a funny guy these two start
flirting but Sam is a little bit crazy
sees things as puppets and when security
comes for him there's a hilarious scene
of ultraviolent puppet action so Sam's
going to kill the main scientist of the
woods but his new friends bust in to
stop him in fact it's Emma who eats the
spaghetti which wow makes her grow real
big but then something weird happens cuz
it immediately cuts to the next morning
yeah none of the group remember last
night cuz apparently they had an awesome
party Marie and Jordan slept together
yeah they've had a whole Arc and had
just started a little romance but
unfortunately this morning's a little
awkward as for their first time they
were both blacked out out but pretty
soon they realize they all blacked out
and when Sam comes to find them they
don't remember him they realize someone
erased their memories and their top
suspect is psychic douche ruus Marie had
a runin with him earlier where he tried
to use his powers for some sexual
assault but she used her powers to
explode his dick so they tried to track
him down but that's hard to do when he
can make you forget what you were doing
but soon they realize it wasn't Rufus
their memories were erased by their
friend Kate we get her tragic backstory
of how she accidentally killed her
brother then her mom locked her up it
was Dean and de JY of gulin University
who was the first person to show her
kindness but she's a master manipulator
who was using Kate to convinced her
erasing her friend's memory was the
right thing to do in fact for years
while they were transferring Sam's power
into Luke she convinced her to erase her
boyfriend's memory too but now Kate
realizes she was being used is ready to
expose Dean chett and the woods now the
main project of the woods is to make a
virus that can nullify Powers vot wants
a way to control their soups and it only
makes them a little sick but turns out
Dean Shetty has her own agenda she has
the scientist make it a deadly virus her
family was killed in that homelander
plane crash so now she wants to kill all
soups without knowing which adults they
can trust Our Gang hopes to expose this
to Victoria Newman yes the congresswoman
from the boys who's now running for vice
president on a very reasonable platform
of soup oversight but the country is
more polarized than ever following the
season 3 finale where homelander lasered
a guy and got cheered for it that has
unfortunately kickstarted a new soup
Supremacy movement but Newman's happy to
talk to Marie Maro the guardian of gulan
a minor celebrity but it's more than
that she reveals her secret remember
she's a soup with blood Powers too and
she also grew up in that orphanage has
been keeping an eye on Murray and wants
to be her Mentor so Murray tells her
about the woods and it's like great
don't worry I got this she convinces the
scientists to give her the virus but she
doesn't expose it she explodes his head
yeah remember she's got her own Sinister
agenda so now our crew has captured DEET
and she reveals the woods isn't new the
whole purpose of gulin is to study soups
Kate feeling incredibly betrayed makes
Dean shett kill herself then she and Sam
go down to the lab for a full Woods
prison break they understandably have a
lot of pent up rage but they take it out
not on vot but in a kill all humans
murder spree Emma tries to talk Sam out
of this they had a deep connection spent
the whole episode doing it but Sam
accidentally went to a party where he
quickly got radicalized in the
anti-human camp so now he's actually
really mean to Emma she feels real small
and in fact she gets real small maybe
found a new way to use her power Andre
and Kate had also fallen in love but he
can't talk her out of this she's
committed so Sam and Andre have a big
fight to where in the end they basically
take each other down and by the way
Andre's dad was in the hospital because
turns out using his powers is killing
him and by extension Andre is too so now
it's Carnage on the campus and it's up
to Marie the guardian of gulin to save
it and with lots of blood laying around
this is her time to shine takes out the
rest of the rampaging soups Kate goes to
use her powers on Jordan but Marie blows
off her hand and the day is saved now an
adult soup arrives on the scene oh snap
it's homelander and he's not happy with
how this played out he chastises Marie
for protecting the humans by fighting
other soups and so oh it's laser time
but he didn't kill her Marie survived
and the rest of her friends are all here
too apparently homelander spun the story
to make them the villains and Kate and
Sam the heroes who stopped them so our
crew is locked up who knows where and
that's where season 1 comes to an end if
you like this recap hit that subscribe
button for more of the best Recaps of TV
and
movies